[Musik]
die gewalt hat südafrika fest im griff
überfälle und morde sind auf der
tagesordnung
[Musik]
menschen werden wegen ihrer hautfarbe
diskriminiert und attackiert südafrika
projektionsfläche für viele schweizer
mit fernweh
eine regenbogen nation im frieden mit
sich selbst und der welt
[Musik]
wie würden sie höchsten mitgeschrieben
dokument der drei um mehr klappte leider
vernichtet wurde war für mich klar es
gibt keine beweise dafür dass sie zu
zielen werden weil sie weiße farmer sind
[Musik]
eine kleine farm außerhalb von
johannesburg
rolf thiel hält nun noch ein paar schafe
früher war das anders
eur in q1 vom ramadan spurtet in erfurt
foto stock und möchte mit der fröhlich
bilder aus besseren zeiten hatte schon
als kind von einem eigenen bauernhof
geträumt vor 50 jahren waren der der
nach südafrika aus und wurde schließlich
pharma wie viel haben sie die besten
momente zwischen 40 und rammte
heimatgeschäft tun
[Musik]
seine kühe waren sein ganzer stolz aber
die wirtschaftliche lage verschlechterte
sich zusehends
sein betrieb hätte wachsen müssen um zu
überleben aber dafür fehlte das geld
also hat es eine kühle schweren herzens
verkauft und hält sich nun mit einer
kleinen ahv aus der schweiz über wasser
eigentlich wollte er einen dicken strich
unter sein farm leben ziehen ob es eine
frau sei auf die bremse getreten
heute sei er dankbar dafür dass sie ihn
vom umzug in eine stadt abgehalten habe
ein einfallstor der positive dinge sich
das klima ändert also ein ziemlich kalte
winter aber viel zone sieht man dass das
sicheren grosser pluspunkt und wenn das
städtische so schön wenn wir dann gehört
da ich mir leichter weg eine art
südafrikanische lahm die der chef ist
auch pharma
die beiden sind nachbarn früher war als
viele stammkunden kein wort folglich
heute braucht er nur noch ab und zu
einen sack hundefutter
die sicherheit ist ein dauerthema
fast jeder wurde schon zum opfer auch
robin vor einer weile hatten wir hier
viele vier diebstähle auch bei rolf sie
haben es versucht
ja sie haben das versucht er hat uns
alarmiert und wir sind sofort mit
nachtsichtgeräten gekommen wir haben
alle schafe gefunden und konnten sie ihn
zurückgeben
er hat kein einziges verloren die form
helfen sich gegenseitig ein notruf
genügt
ich schätze dass sie ich bin inzwischen
73 also kein jungspund mehr so gut dass
wir nachbarn haben auf die wir uns
verlassen können
sie haben sich zwar auf bürgerwehr
zusammengeschlossen farm wort nennt sich
das wir machen uns sorgen denn die
angriffe auf farmen nehmen zu ich weiß
dass die polizei versucht die situation
in den griff zu bekommen
aber das wird nicht gelingen die haben
gar nicht die ressourcen dafür
darum haben sie ihre sicherheit selber
in die hand genommen
die beule unter dem hemd ist eine
pistole
er habe einen waffen- und einen tragen
scheint also alles ganz legal und bitter
nötig denn es werde immer ungemütlicher
hier sollen die spannungen bewusst
geschürt werden
der weißen minderheit die uns unser land
mit gewalt weggenommen hat müsst ihr
sagen genug ist genug
wir nehmen die zukunft in unserer
eigenen hände
bei jedem auftritt stimmt der
linkspopulistische oppositionsführer ein
inzwischen verbotenes liedern
wir haben nicht dazu aufgerufen weise zu
töten jedenfalls noch nicht ich kann
nichts garantieren für die zukunft
verstehen sie dass die leute die das
hören ausflippen werden
es klingt wie eine flucht zum genozid
susan boyle susan ich rufe nicht dazu
auf weiße abzuschlachten noch nicht
ich kann nichts garantieren für die
zukunft vor allem wenn es so weitergeht
so wächst wenn es so weitergeht wird es
eine revolution geben in diesem land das
kann ich ihnen jetzt schon sagen es wird
eine unkontrollierte revolution geben
und das ist die höchste form der
anarchie
genau das wollte nelson mandela
verhindern
nach seiner freilassung hat er einen
großen traum er wollte schwarze und
weiße versöhnen
[Applaus]
nie nie nie wieder soll es in diesem
land vorkommen dass jemand einen anderen
unterdrückt
[Musik]
die zeit der schönen worte scheint
vorbei zu sein
heute schützt sich wer kann also da
immer noch immer nur normale sicherheit
das ich je 4 ohm monitor und der
schweizer models nach der kurzen pause
kunde und den privatteams eine frau löst
in bewegungsmelder aus
juli amerika und das wird dann passieren
wenn man das ausschaut hat der hund
übertragen
also schluss dass ich nun lokal sie
wüssten jemand ist im haus und könnten
die nachbarn aufbieten wird
das bedeutet mord an farmen in afrikaans
der sprache der buren
jedes dieser kreuze die auf einem hügel
nördlich der hauptstadt pretoria
aufgestellt wurden stieg für einen
ermordeten weißen farmer
[Musik]
am sonntag wird grilliert 3 nennt sich
das ein stück normalität in ihm
außergewöhnlicheren zeiten
entschuldigung das also eine strikte hat
seine tochter und deren freunde sind
vorbeigekommen
sie mögen die ruhe und die landluft am
wochenende aber auf einer farm leben und
arbeiten
für mich ist das vermutlich nichts ich
würde sowieso lieber nach übersee
auswandern als in südafrika zu bleiben
es ist ja völlig unklar wie lange ihre
familie noch auf diese form bleiben wird
genau das weiß ich darum würde ich am
liebsten nach übersee gehen möglichst
weit weg von hier
sind sie denn sarah bewaffnet in ihrer
wahl für den job im schlafzimmer wo er
in der schublade und die waffe nicht
klar da war für mich klar dass ich aber
keine patronen im lauf ok hat sie schon
mal braucht nur noch mit halber und 1 nv
wie baby würde ich weiß dass neue die
heute ich weiß nicht wen ich trainiere
ich weiß das wird gar nicht
bilder aus zeiten der apartheid damals
galt so genannte rassentrennung auch am
strand die weißen unter sich die
schwarzen wollen dass rassismus als
staatsform diese rassismus wurde durch
einflussreiche buren organisationen wie
die rechtsextremen afrikaner
widerstandsbewegung kurz abb geradezu
zelebriert
sie waren strikt gegen die abschaffung
der apartheid
[Musik]
wir können nicht mitbestimmen die sind
dazu nicht fähig die haben eine andere
kultur und tradition als wir weisen ihr
trainiert um zu töten werde die schwarze
töten wenn wir angegriffen werden gehen
wie in die offensive dann ist es
natürlich erlaubt zu töten
die awb wappnete sich nach mandelas
freilassung gegen einen möglichen
ausstand der schwarzen
wir trainieren aus liebe zum volk um es
zu schützen vor dem ensi der uns unser
land wegnehmen
wir werden sie alle abknallen mein
freund bis keiner mehr bei euch ist
alles schien auf einen bürgerkrieg
hinauszulaufen
[Applaus]
als sich die südafrikanerin bessie und
der schweizer rolf kennen und lieben
lernten herrschte nach apartheid und so
genannte mission waren gesetzlich
verboten
die das als kathedrale in jahres wird
auch immer mehr schweizer nach und
ständig zum gerät ein naturwunder
behandeln
ich habe mich offiziell erklären als
ihre farbe als farbige dass ich
überhaupt noch eine höhere typische hier
wurde kaka provinzen und habe gefragt
und die hat reagiert dass ihr kein
problem
kein problem während der apartheid
mussten wir natürlich dem gesetz
gehorchen dass es zb um neun uhr abends
durften wir nicht mehr unterwegs sein
also wir schwarzen und farbigen aber man
muss auch sagen
damals gab es keine kriminalität wir
konnten draußen schlafen und die türen
einfach offen lassen
[Musik]
steht für die systematische
unterdrückung der schwarzen
bevölkerungsmehrheit durch die weiße
minderheit der widerstand wuchs stetig
wurde aber lange brutal niedergeschlagen
[Musik]
nelson mandela suchte nach der apartheid
die versöhnung eine der zentralen fragen
war eine gerechte teilung des landes
mandela hoffte dieses problem werde sich
von allein lösen
dem war allerdings nicht so man kann von
der erbsünde dieses landes sprechen den
ursprünglichen bewohnern südafrikas ihr
land wegzunehmen
das war die erbsünde weiß sie
kontrollieren immer noch 70 prozent der
landwirtschaftlichen flächen ein reiz
und wahlkampfthema in unserem manifest
legen wir da wie wir eine landreform
beschleunigen wollen
dazu gehören auch enteignungen ohne
entschädigung
[Musik]
auch rolf spiels familie könnte schon
bald enteignet werden beschäftigte sie
dass sie ihnen die fahne wegnehmen
könnten ja natürlich beschäftigt mich
dass wir haben so hart gearbeitet für
diese farm die können doch nicht einfach
kommen und sie uns wegnehmen
vielleicht können sie
robert mugabe hat es im nachbarland
simbabwe vorgemacht
anfang der 2000er jahre bevor auch hier
eine so genannte landreform das hieß
konkret weiße farmer wurden systematisch
enteignet und vertrieben
sie haben uns angerufen und nur gesagt
ihr habt zwei tage um von der farm zu
verschwinden
wer konnte flüchtete viele andere wurden
umgebracht
die einstige kornkammer afrikas wurde
innert kürzester zeit zu einem armenhaus
gezeichnet von hungersnöten und
unterernährung nur durch
hilfslieferungen aus dem ausland am
leben erhalten
[Musik]
rolf spiel hofft dass südafrika diese
sogenannte simbabwe szenario erspart
bleibt
im interesse des landes und natürlich
auch in seinem eigenen so groß im moment
waren wir im moment noch im verkauf von
münchen kommend ja heute könnte er
keinen berater nach südafrika
auszuwandern
zu seiner zeit sei es allerdings noch
ein land der chancen gewesen
anwaltliche sponsoren rico nach der
letzten woche nach kanada wo nach
australien neuseeland und südafrika
ich bin eigentlich das land
warum bist du passt die hände glück
sucht und sucht wo kinder und
installateur der schweiz und die handys
der interflug zahlten verbliebe zahlten
ihm anfang bis zur nabe kunden hat ich
habe immer viel theorie oder zwei gut
wie jetzt an 350 wisse noch herzlich
willkommen sie jeden fall ja richtig wie
würden sie heute stehen mit beschrieben
moment sind eine phase geben oder
vielleicht moment wo sie hatte trug ist
ja sicher wie und da ja jetzt schon
sagen wenn ich wenig zeit haben ihre
wurzeln sind ziemlich düster obwohl
obwohl die natur und ohren spitzt sich
letztmalig der schweiz sieht man in
münchen
ja früher 20 jahren ja ewig
[Gelächter]
fluggerät sache nicht mal kaufen und mit
der die schüler thema der schau
botticelli nato an anderer stelle
[Musik]
das gefühl ein richtiger hype im jahr
so wie du township siedlungen im
südwesten von johannesburg
hier mögen sie nicht mehr auf eine
gerechtere verteilung des landes warten
hier nehmen sie sich land und bauen
darauf diese siedlung als protein und
hat inzwischen sogar einen
gemeindeleiter der selbstbewusste
forderungen hat an den südafrikanischen
staat und die regierung muss uns helfen
und diese straße instand setzen
die regierung wird sagen ihr lebt auf
besetztem land ja aber inzwischen sind
wir hier zu hause
wir bleiben ja hier und besetzen nicht
einfach weiteres land außer man würde es
uns anbieten hier wohne ich seit war
seit 2005 10 stand dieser sei es damals
schon nein ich habe es gekauft und will
es war so ich habe mir dieses land
genommen und ein haus aufgestellt
sie haben sich das land einfach genommen
ja ich habe es mir einfach genommen und
wie fühlen sie sich jetzt
ich fühle mich toll wenn ich mir dieses
land nicht genommen hätte hätte ich
jetzt kein zuhause
ich bin stolz auf das was ich getan habe
ich weiß es ist falsch aber es ist jetzt
mein zuhause
sie sagen es sei falsch was genau der
besitzer des landes würde wohl sagen
dass es meins mir geht es schlecht aber
ich habe keine wahl ich brauche ein
zuhause das ist meine küche ihr essen
wir das ist mein schlafzimmer schlafe
ich es mein bett folgen
und hier schlafen meine kinder
wer kein land hat muss sie sich nehmen
so sehen es inzwischen viele
wir werden kämpfen
das ist unser land wir werden bleiben
wir gehen nirgendwo hin er ist vor vier
jahren von südafrika in die schweiz
umgezogen peter bernhardt und seine frau
carmen würden allerdings auch gerne
wieder zurück
selbstverständlich würde man sofort heim
kamen ist vorrunde
ich bin bald also sagte ceo permanent
und ich sehe jetzt 40 jahren mit der
monotonie und trotzdem nutzt und herren
es ist keine option mehr würde es sofort
wieder zurück aber es mir ist ja
normalität sie bis es soweit ist führen
sie ein restaurant kanton aargau er hat
seine berufliche karriere in der
gastronomie in der schweiz angefangen
wurde dann in südafrika groß pharma ist
nun zurück in der schweiz und richtet
wieder salat termin schon im moment bin
ich gut als geschätztes kalbfleisch
jetzt kann ich kann nicht der familie
mitglied verliere durch kriminalität
durch sie heißen brutalität und es ist
ja nicht so dass es harmlose
kriminalität ist dass sie nur ein gewerk
name sondern für sie überhaupt nicht
wert im moment und das will ich meine
familie hatte er ging mit leeren taschen
nach südafrika arbeitete hart und
investierte schlauer
das ist erwischen falschen nostalgie der
gremien schon fast wieder trennen die
bayern haben hautnah miterlebt wie die
gewalt in ihrem kleinen paradies zu
eskalieren begann er hätte 3 und klappt
und der trauung geklappt hat ist leider
vernichtet wurde
mehrere tausend kita riesige verwiesen
verhandelt worden sind nicht zum sagen
sie nur wie sie farmer aber sehr sehr
viel wie sie kamen der landwirte gebiert
da die devise vorne effektiv dezimiert
einen teil seines landes verpachtet er
nun den rest managt ein angestellter für
seine familie sagen nur noch eine
möglichkeit aus südafrika flüchten an
alarmanlage megane licht und wind werde
ab und zu wieder vergiftet es ist nicht
der nacht wo die effektiv ruhig kein
stures laufe es geht man die nacht wenn
ich nur das worauf gestanden drei
viermal fünfmal in der nacht antwort das
hat der hund mal gegen das muss nicht
unbedingt angebracht und erniedrigung
sieht das haus lange sie oder sonstiges
willst aber wenn alarm nicht ergangen
sind umzüge summe der präsident
zehn millimeter wieder runter und
friseure und skrupel in den unteren bett
k26 kann temporär soll her glaubt und so
leben immer mehr südafrikaner stellt das
institut für sicherheitsstudien in
pretoria fest
es sei nicht nur ein gefühl es werde
tatsächlich immer schlimmer sagt gareth
newham die kriminalitätsraten steigen
und sind erklärbar die fähigkeiten des
staates die organisierte kriminalität zu
bekämpfen sind weitgehend verschwunden
das ist ein erbe der von korruption
gezeichneten ära unseres ex präsidenten
jacob zuma
er hat viele fähige leute entlassen und
seine günstlinge eingesetzt auch bei der
polizei und der justiz
die waren inkompetenz also stieg die
kriminalität an
aber auch weil sich die wirtschaft
abgekühlt hat mehr arbeitslosigkeit
ungleichheit und armut führen zu mehr
kriminalität an einem tatort
[Musik]
sandra van ziel betreibt eine erfahren
und wurde kürzlich brutal überfallen
als ich diese tür geöffnet habe standen
plötzlich sechs bewaffnete schwarze mit
sturmhauben vor mir ich habe versucht
die tür zu schließen
aber sie haben sofort angefangen mich
ins gesicht zu boxen
sie haben mir die ganze zeit mit den
waffen auf den kopf geschlagen und
geschrien wo ist das geld [ __ ] sie
haben mich gezwungen mich nackt
auszuziehen
sie sagten mir sie würden mich jetzt
vergewaltigen
sie haben mir alle kleider vom leib
gerissen und wollten dass ich mich dort
drüben hinsetze herzlich kam einer mit
kochendem wasser
sie fingen an mir das kochende wasser
ins ohr zu gießen
das war ein grauenvoller schmerz ein
bekanntes muster unbekannte hier gefilmt
von einer überwachungskamera dringen
irgendwo ein um ihre opfer dann nicht
nur zu berauben sondern auch stundenlang
zu foltern
diese gewalt ist meist gut erklärbar
einerseits wollen sie damit herausfinden
wo die opfer alle möglichen wertsachen
versteckt haben
andererseits kann es aber auch um
machtfragen innerhalb der gang gehen
die opfer werden gequält um der eigenen
gang zu sagen wenn ihr nicht auf mich
hört mache ich das auch mit euch
es gibt also oft gründe für die
scheinbar sinnlose gewalt
opfer wie sandra von ziel wird nicht
aufgrund ihrer hautfarbe ausgewählt
kriminelle hätten nur ein interesse
beute machen möglichst viel möglichst
schnell es geht den tätern
ausschließlich um den zugang zu
wertsachen
die meisten opfer sind nicht weiß
sondern schwarz aus der mittelklasse die
in städten wonach die haben ipads
mobiltelefone und schmuck klar weiße
farmer scheinen geld zu haben und werden
darum zum zielen
aber es gibt keine beweise dafür dass
sie zu zielen werden weil sie weiß sind
oder weiße farmer sind
ich denke definitiv dass sie gezielt
weiße aussuchen
ganz sicher sie haben mich ja die ganze
zeit weiße [ __ ] genannt
schon ihre sprache war voller hass gehen
weiß eine große versöhnung mit diesem
traum findet das moderne südafrika an
wir schließen einen bund in dem alle
südafrikaner schwarz oder weiß keine
angst mehr haben müssen
sie sollen wissen dass wir ihnen ihre
menschenwürde garantieren werden
eine regenbogen nation im frieden mit
sich selbst und der welt
wag
was für einen witz nelson mandelas traum
er glaubt er als junger mann tatsächlich
dass wir hier alle friedlich zusammen
leben werden
wenn er gewusst hätte was alles noch
kommt er wäre sicher sehr enttäuscht von
seinem volk schrecklich enttäuscht
zurück in der schweiz
bei peter bernhardt seiner frau und
deren tochter sie führten ein
glückliches leben in südafrika bis die
ehefrau eines abends nicht nach hause
kam
sie war entführt worden und tauchte erst
am nächsten morgen wieder auf ihrem mann
fand sich schließlich nachhaltig
traumatisiert vom erlebten dann so
schnell wie möglich ins privatspital
nach krieges gab sie den und sie meinen
sie denn untersucht mein gott sei dank
alles gemacht sagte sie
ich frage mich heute gesund aber sie
hätte dadurch angeregt und das ist für
familie ganz so schlimm ist auch gesehen
möchte man erlebe das ist eine für den
effekt dass morgen das paradies hendrix
klar
ihr kind eine frage zu ersetzen ist
möglich alles andere kamen ersetze mehr
kann ich dazu nichts arges kopf für den
anderen südafrika genau ich von mir sind
in der situation war mein könig sehr
viel an die mächtigen können nico weil
sie genau wissen können wir sie aufs
sozialamt in welchen getan hinderte sie
wollen nicht weg und sie können auch
nicht aber vielleicht müssen sie schon
bald
und ich werde jetzt das für euch wenn
der regen ein die farm ist halo wird zum
beispiel enteignet also eher tragisch da
gehst du mal war tragisch und ich war
mir so viel weil ja meint man hinter
aufbaute so unglücklich da und wenn doch
nach unten seite ist neben der direkten
würde wieder wäre
[Musik]